[Música]
bueno buenas tardes a todos ahorita que
venía para acá venía el coche y tenía
demasiado calor no se imaginan la
cantina ahorita la temperatura en poble
es impresionante y ahorita ustedes
vienen de allá afuera y me gustaría
preguntarles si tuvieron la oportunidad
de elegir entre una bebida entre un
recipiente de plástico
o uno de vidrio cuando elegiría levanten
la mano a los que elijan un envase de
vidrio
y los que eligen un envase de plástico
muy poquitos bueno a lo mejor puedo
tener la respuesta a esa pregunta
por ejemplo por que elegirían vidrio
seguramente va a decir el sabor cierto
bueno resulta que ese sabor es debido
principalmente a que el vidrio no libera
sustancias sin embargo el plásticos y el
plástico haber revolucionado muchísimo
de nuestra vida ha mejorado nos ha
facilitado prácticamente todo lo que
tenemos a nuestro alrededor
tanto así por ejemplo que los plásticos
se utilizan para todo y decían que eran
tan seguro que por ejemplo podríamos
tener un bebé en una bolsa de celofán a
partir de ahí viendo esta seguridad de
los plásticos empezó a revolucionar la
producción de plástico se elevó a cerca
de 300 300 millones de toneladas en el
mundo eso ha sido abismal y de hecho lo
vemos en todas partes
myler decía a veces pienso que hay una
fuerza maligna suelta en el universo que
es el equivalente al social alcance se
llama plástico se infiltra en todo es
metastásico y se pone en cada uno de los
poros de la vida productiva y vean a su
alrededor en donde están sentados el
tipo de ropa el tipo de artículos que
tienen y entonces lo vemos en las
bebidas en botellas que seguramente yo
yo creo que consumieron habitan algunas
afuera contenedores de plástico
alimentos pre calentados en recipientes
de plástico vayan al supermercado y lo
primero que eligen es un alimento en
este tipo de contenedores en los litros
de medicamentos en los productos de
belleza tienen demasiados plastificantes
en los coches
pequeño detalle a lo mejor ustedes van a
un centro comercial en un coche nuevo se
suben y qué aroma expide se siente rico
no lo aprovechan es más hasta se
encierran en el coche cierto creo que sí
y es más cuando tienen su coche nuevo lo
ponen a las 12 del día se suben a su
coche le suben las ventanillas para que
no se le vaya el aroma al coche nuevo
bueno lo que está respirando ahí son
plastificantes productos que es
sustancias que se liberan de todos los
todos estos plásticos lo peor
peor aún vemos plásticos que están
consumiendo nuestros bebés
obviamente encontramos plásticos en
todas partes hasta en el mar encontramos
plásticos
les voy a comentar algo que me pasó
resulta que cuando yo esté yo soy de
formación biólogo yo no quería estudiar
biología yo quería estudiar medicina
porque porque yo quería ayudar a
muchísimas personas
y ver y tratar de ayudar a la mayor
cantidad posible de humanos
lamentablemente que aún todavía
desconozco nos no entré a medicina /
biología pero sabía que biología tenía
algo diferente tenía muchas áreas de
trabajo a donde yo pudiera estudiar y
entonces probé de todo no quiere decir
unos churros no quiere decir unos
arponazos pero probé por ejemplo otras
áreas otras series de investigación y me
encontré con algo muy interesante
en mis primeros pininos después de haber
salido de la carrera me dediqué a la
biología reproductiva es decir como
a generar o cómo mejorar o ayudar a
aquellas parejas que no podían tener
bebés entonces para mí era duro era
difícil poder decir por ejemplo muchas
parejas no pueden tener bebés se
deprimía y entonces obviamente me
dediqué a esa línea de investigación
hizo una maestría en biología de la
reproducción
manipulación de gametos obtener
embriones como podemos ver en esta
imagen tener un bebé y finalmente tener
un bebé en casa era bonito ver esas
parejas que pudieran salir del hospital
y pudieran tener su bebé en casa sin
embargo
hubo algo que me marcó
esta película que se llama de los niños
del hombre de hecho es una película de
alfonso cuarón si toda la mujer la hayan
visto acuérdense que menciona que en
algún momento si para ser exacto en el
2023 ya no tenemos la capacidad de
podernos reproducir entonces era algo
difícil entonces esto me marcó yo no le
hice caso tanto al película porque sea
ciencia ficción pero ya conforme fuimos
estudiando fuimos avanzando en esto
porque en este en estas investigaciones
resulta que si estaba sucediendo
no a veíamos problemas de infertilidad
sino la manera de cómo nos estábamos
reproduciendo y entonces cómo es la
población ahorita personas obesas
varios estudios han demostrado que por
ejemplo la población mexicana tiene un
problema de obesidad esto es lo que pasa
con jóvenes pero con niños de edades
entre 5 a 12 años es lo que pasa con los
jóvenes para la mayoría de ustedes pero
cuando yo basen más de los 20 años de
edad esto lo que va a suceder entonces
es dramático y entonces a quién le
echamos la culpa la mayoría hicimos
productos porque consumen más en
ejercicio
consumen muchas gracias etcétera
bueno esa es una parte si así nos
estamos reproduciendo pero tenemos
enfermedades pero también nos estamos
muriendo de que nos morimos bueno
diabetes mellitus
tumores malignos enfermedades hepáticas
enfermedades pulmonares y algunas
malformaciones congénitas es decir ya
tenemos alguna deformación desde de
nacimiento bueno
pero
[Música]
ya nos morimos no pasa nada total se
acabó pero el detalle que tenemos es que
hemos visto qué
varias sustancias se están teniendo
efectos a largo plazo
un estudio del ciclo
demostró por ejemplo que el peso
corporal por el consumo de plásticos se
da transgeneracional
como pueden ver en esta gráfica tenemos
99 barritas las últimas barras son de
crías de ratoncitos que consume cuyos
padres consumieron plastificantes en
es lo que sucede en la pubertad la
pubertad se nos está adelantando las
niñas tienen sus primeras menstruaciones
entre los 8 y 9 años cuando lo normal
debería ser entre los 10 a 12 años
entonces está adelantando y el otro
problema
están volviendo infértiles tres
generaciones es decir sus abuelos y sus
papás cuando se inició la revolución de
los plastificantes que fueron más o
menos en la década de los 60 de los 70s
tenía estaban en la plena evolución de
los plásticos
a lo mejor dejamos de consumirlos pero
sabemos ahora que mis ni mis hijos y mis
nietos van a tener este tipo de
problemas
y bueno pero no solamente se ven
malformaciones nos íbamos a volver
infértiles no nos vamos a volver obesos
es lo de menos y el problema que tenemos
es que ahora hay datos que mencionan que
estas sustancias tienen problemas
neurodegenerativas es decir no nos está
llegando agua al tinaco es decir no nos
está llegando al cerebro o que tenemos
problemas neurodegenerativos dejamos de
pensar y este estudio es muy bonito en
donde l barc factor ni pat estudia el
coeficiente intelectual de los niños
en los cuales se encontraron estos
plastificantes y fíjense lo que sucede
la velocidad de procesamiento en la
columna verde quiere decir que no hay
los niveles de plástico son bajos en las
otras dos barras tienen demasiados ok el
coeficiente intelectual se nos viene
abajo
la memoria de trabajo y el razonamiento
yo pensaba que mis estudiantes
tenían problemas sociales siempre
estaban distraídos etcétera y ahora sé
que no el efecto de los plastificantes
tiene efecto sobre su razonamiento
entonces aquí tengo que trabajar con
ellos y entonces una de las pioneras en
estas áreas de problemas reproductivos y
efectos tóxicos de varias sustancias en
el medio ambiente es el doctor agudo
dirían uno de los recientes trabajos
demostró concluyó que hay suficiente
evidencia que la reducción de
coeficiente intelectual es debido a las
poca la exposición de plásticos y eso lo
estamos viendo en la actualidad cierto
no a veces tenemos un compañerito por
ahí que le falta poquito o un tornillo
por ahí etcétera
pero vamos a incrementar las cosas les
decía que la innovación y el desarrollo
puede ser benéfico pero tiene efectos
perjudiciales
una vez avances e innovaciones ha sido
por ejemplo las maneras de cómo vivimos
desarrollamos técnicas o tecnologías
para mejorar nuestro estilo de vida y
entre ellas tenemos lo que van a ser el
microondas bello aparato facilita todo
calienta rápido en menos de dos o tres
minutos y qué es lo que sucede vamos al
supermercado compramos recipientes de
plástico y los alimentos ahí los metemos
los sacamos del microondas y listo para
comer el problema que está generando eso
es que el calentamiento que genera el
microondas puede facilitar la liberación
de estas toxinas y entonces
hicimos un experimento les voy a
comentar esto que hicimos hace un par de
años en donde colocamos agua en un
recipiente de plástico este recipiente
de plástico locales lo metimos al
microondas y esta agua se la dimos a
tomar a unos ratoncitos
obviamente sus ratoncitos vamos a ver
qué es lo que les pasó bueno resulta
hindú hcieron un daño a sus
espermatozoides las células masculinas
que les va a permitir tener un bebé
en el gráfico a pueden ver células
normales pero cuando les damos
plastificante eso es decir el agua
calentada en un recipiente de plástico
entre comillas seguro ok lo que hace es
que deshace el espermatozoide literal
como lo pueden ver en las gráficas que
hice
si yo le incremento el sobrepeso es
clásico en población mexicana
la k es la calidad del espermatozoide
pues cdn a ese núcleo es es esa célula
se deshace en su totalidad y esto lo que
nos está generando muchos problemas de
infertilidad esperemos que no se
embaracen que sería lo mejor pero el
problema que tenemos es que esos daños
esos mínimos daños que tiene el
espermatozoide pueden llegar al óvulo
pueden generar un bebé y ese bebé va a
tener muchas alteraciones y yo creo que
lo vamos a ver en un futuro y entonces
qué es lo que nos depara el futuro cuál
es nuestro horizonte ahorita ustedes qué
harán de aquí en adelante para evitar
que tengamos esas alteraciones
creo que los deprime perdón
no lo voy a hacer
y les agradezco muchísimo su atención
[Música]